Near the arctic circle in Siberia
is the world’s coldest permanently inhabited town
Its residents deserve our respect
and our sympathies
I'm from Minnesota, so I know cold
but it is nothing on the level
what the residents of Oymyakon have to deal with
So for six months out of the year, from October to March
the temperature is always below freezing
to give you some perspective, the average temperatures in January
are equivalent to the temperatures on Mars
the coldest temperature ever recorded there
was negative ninety
I don’t know what happens at negative ninety. I imagine that, that you just die
If you go outside you just instantly die
It has to be negative sixty degrees
before they tell the kids to stay home from school
This creates all kinds of strange problems
they have to leave their cars idling
batteries just immediately die
electronics in general are basically useless
the air is actually sucking the moisture out of your body
when someone dies in Oymyakon during the winter
they have to light a bonfire, let it burn for half a day
dig down about a foot, and then do the same thing over, it can take days
On the plus side, all it takes to refrigerate you food is a basement
can you just throw your carcasses down there
they eat a lot of frozen meat
two go snacks are cubes of frozen reindeer blood
and thinly sliced reindeer or horse meat
what do the people of Oymyakon do for fun?
Besides drinking, of which they do a fair amount
One of the thing they do is participate in something called the Walrus Club
which involves finding a river, in the middle of winter
and jumping into it
and think the part that is fun, is that you don’t die
So from a man who grew up in the world’s third coldest place
to the residents of the world’s first coldest place
Za Vashe Zdorovie (За  ваше здоровье)
Subscribe here and watch more videos here
We used to do this thing where you could take a cup of boiling water
throw the boiling water into the air
and it would never hit the ground
it would just disappear into a puff of steam
it would sort of sublimate into the air
that was awesome, that’s a great thing to do when it’s really cold out
what are some other wonders that I should know about!
What do you want to hear me talk about, what do you want to tell me about
what is the greatest place you have ever been
I want to know all of these things